roddy slave découvre sa classe et
s'apprête à vivre sa première rentrée à
l'école élémentaire 17 dire pin
j'aime beaucoup cette classe
j'ai hâte de commencer à étudier avec ma
maîtresse
les enseignants préparent les salles
après plusieurs mois de fermeture à
cause de la guerre les cours ont
continué en distance yale via internet
ici le plaisir de se retrouver est
palpable
l'enseignement est ma passion ça mais
pas nui j'adorerais avec les enfants ils
m'ont énormément manqué
on devine ce n'est pas la même chose ni
pour moi ni pour eux il manque la
présence physique
bronislaw a pu voir sa classe en
avant-première parce que sa maman
natalia est enseignant dans cette école
tout l'établissement est en travaux
natalia est venu préparer sa classe pour
ses élèves sur 32 selon seront présents
je m'inquiète pour la sécurité des
enfants qui seront en classe avec moi
convenez l'enseignement en ligne et en
présentiel me paraît compliqué
[Musique]
j'espère qu'il n'y aura pas trop d'
alerte
que tout sera calme
les écoles l'ukrainienne ne sont
autorisés a rouvert leurs portes que si
elles ont un abri antibombes ici on a
utilisé des blocs de béton pour en
augmenter la capacité mais même avec ces
travaux l'école ne pourra accueillir que
300 élèves sur les 2000 qu'elle compte
habituellement